armed groups from Democratic Republic of
Congo met in Nairobi for peace talks
absent was M23 widely understood to be a
proxy of neighboring Rwanda
about 300 000 people have fled m23's
recent advances in eastern Congo it
refused to withdraw and disarm by a
deadline that passed 10 days ago and so
it was excluded from the talks Rwanda
whose soldiers have been photographed
with M23 Fighters denies backing the
group
in Nairobi a former Kenyan president
Uhuru Kenyatta was facilitating the
talks
I want to say the problem is foreign
groups engaging in Congo and leaving
destruction the same groups need to
engage with their governments and leave
Congo in peace
it's a problem that's lasted decades
over which Uganda and Rwanda have earned
vast profits from Congo's minerals most
of the representatives of armed groups
here say they only picked up arms in the
first place in the 1990s when Uganda and
Rwanda invaded Congo and they say unless
the problem of foreign armed groups and
foreign-backed armed groups is resolved
and unless the Congolese Army can
actually protect their communities
there's no way that they will lay down
their weapons
the president of one of the more than 50
armed groups represented here
we first met him five years ago we were
covering a series of ethnically targeted
massacres in eastern Congo he denied his
group as responsible
he told us in Nairobi he needs to
continue defending his community it's
not possible to put down guns whereas
they are killing in our country in our
people are being
killed by the foreign groups such as M23
from Rwanda from Uganda
thousands of people from Jean-Claude
kawaii's Community have fled the
fighting we met him in Congo two weeks
ago
he says they can only go home if Rwanda
is forced to stop its military
aggression
he wants the East African Community
which hosted the Nairobi talks and
Western countries to sanction Rwanda and
so he's disappointed that the European
Union has just given Rwanda 21 million
dollars of military aid
when the European Union sends money it
isn't a way financing rwanda's operation
in Congo and we call upon France the UK
and the USA to stop this hypocrisy
that's the only way we as Congolese can
have a decent life and not live like
animals
the peace talks are due to continue in
January
and if they're to make any progress
almost everyone here says foreign
military meddling in Congo needs to stop
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Nairobi Kenya